[موسيقى]
الارض بالنسبه الي انا يعني في الدم نشات
في اسره
ممتده ما شاء الله ست اخوه وست بنات
والاولاد والاحفاد ما شاء الله يعني لكن
ما زلنا في هذه الارض بناكل من خيرها هي
البيت الكبير اللي لامم كل الاسره بعد ما
اكملت جي اي اعتقلت انا انا بتذكر كانت
السنه الاولى من الانتفاضه الانتفاضه
الاولى عام
88 وكش من الشباب الموجودين ما كانش ممكن
الواحد الا يمارس اعمال الانتفاضه زيه زي
الاف الشباب في البلد يعني فيش امكانيه
تقف متفرج او مكتوف الايدي بعد سنتين
انحكمت سبع سنين وثمانيه عدم تنفيذ هذول
السبع سنين كانوا هم بمثابه يعني المده
الكافيه انه الواحد يدرس الطب في في في
العراق وكانت معاي منحه لكن قدر الله وما
شاء فعل كانت طبعا معاناه شديده تركت
بالتاكيد بصماتها على شخصيتي كانسان وربما
كان لها الاثر الكبير بما في ذلك اختيار
مهنه الصحافه يلا يا
شباب اقعد يا زلمه انت
اقعد و بالنسبه لب ياتي مع الصحافه كانت
مع انتسابي للجامعه وكان يعني امامي قسم
الصحافه والاعلام بالجامعه الاسلاميه كان
اول قسم افتتح في قطاع غزه بعد التخرج
اللي كان في اواخر عام 98 تقريبا يعني
ابتدينا في الصحافه المكتوبه من خلال
صحيفه القدب اجت انتفاضه الاقصى اللي هي
الانتفاضه الثانيه وكانت هذه بمثابه تجربه
جديده بالنسبه ال اللي على مستوى الصحافه
المكتوبه زائد انتقالي الى احدى الاذاعات
المهتمه بالشان الفلسطيني صوت فلسطين الى
ان كانت الانطلاقه الحقيقيه والاهم
بالنسبه لي مع قناه الجزيره في العام
2004 في لحظه واحده ا يعني انقلبت البلد
ما كان في عند عننا احتياطات خبره كبيره
لتغطيه الحروب مش موجوده
مئات الغارات في نفس اللحظه وبنفس التوقيت
وفي مختلف مناطق القطاع ومقرات بتنضرب
وماحدش عارف ايش اللي
[موسيقى]
بصير في غزه التحدي مختلف والتحدي مضاعف
انه انت في خطر واهلك في خطر لما نقرب
الاحتلال المباشر رنوا علي بصعوبه ل
الجوال كانت الدنيا ليل وانا عمال نازل عن
الهوا قولوا لي القذائف صارت تنهمر وتيجي
على البيت اذا بتقدر تعال انقذنا من البيت
طلع ابوك لانه ما بقدر يمشي والحجه امك
فانا بالنسبه ي في هذك اللحظه كانت بمثابه
انهيار لكن ات ملكت نفسي وقلت لهم انا
بالنسسبه الي بقدرش اسويلكم
حاجه
هذه اكبر حاجه بقلمك وتقتلك من الداخل لكن
في نهايه المطاف انت امام تحدي كبير مش بس
اهلك اللي بيتعرضوا للخطر قاعدين كل البلد
وكل الناس اللي في البلد تعرضوا للخطر
وانت عليك
تقرر يا رب يا رب اصبحنا عارفين شو معنى
الحرب شو ممكن يكون عندك قديش عندك يعني
عدد ضخم من الاحداث كله بصير في لحظه
واحده وفي مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه
وبالتالي عليك انه انت تكون اكثر حرفيه
ومهنيه في مواجهه هذه الاحداث وفي اداره
الطاقم وهو هذا تحدي كبير انه انت كيف
تدير الطاقم وتركز على الاحداث اللي
بتختصر المشهد وتجيبها عشان تبثها على
قناه الجزيره ي العافيه يا
شباب كيف
حال العافيه كيف اخباركم كله تمام يلا ايش
جاهزين يلا شباب
اجتماع نقول انه حرب
2014 يمكن من حيث الشده والقسوه والعنف
يمكن بدات من وين انتهت الحربين السابقتين
ولذلك كانت غنيه جدا بالصور المرعبه
والصادم
شباب في قصف علينا يا شباب هي كمان صارخ
كمان ارف كيف تركت حي الشجاعيه تركته مع
الاسف في اسوا حال على الاقل مما شاهدنا
في هذه البرهه القصيره عندما وصلنا الى
المنطقه صدمنا من هول ما راينا على كل
الاصعده حقيقه راينا جثامين للشهداء ملقا
[موسيقى]
على
وفهمنا الرساله يعني وصلتنا الرساله انه
هذا الكلام كان مقصود كانه بقول لك هد
اللعب وشغلك هذا ف زياده كثير ومحرج
بالنسبه لهم كثير ووالى اخره لكن احنا بعد
دقائق معدوده كنا من امام المكتب من
الشارع نطلع على الهواء مباشره بنوصف
حالتنا الى جانب نقلنا لاستمرار الغارات
ال قصف الاسرائيلي هذا الكلام خلى عننا
شعور انه ممكن في اي لحظه نصير احنا يعني
خبر
المقاومه على عجل بشكل عفوي انطلق الناس
الى هذه الساحه كي يعبروا عن
فرحهم بهذه اللحظه التاريخيه يعطيك
العافيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كان موقف حقيقه يعني احنا ما كنا متوقعينه
لكن وجدت انه هذا اكبر جائزه ممكن يتلقاها
اي صحفي فلسطيني وقام بتغطيه هذه الحرب
وهذا تفسير لانه الناس وجدوا انه انت كنت
الوحيد لما كل الناس تخلوا عن هذا الشعب
انت كنت الوحيد ربما اللي شعر انك انت
بتدافع عنهم ولو بالصوره وبكلمه
وبالمعلومات
جيب لهم تعاطف الشعوب في ارجاء المعموره
يا دار الاوف دار تلبق ليك
الاشعار يا دار الاوفى
دار تضوي فيك
الاشعار الداير
المضويه مزروعه مجد
وغار على البرج العالي طلوا الخياله بسيوف
تلالي شمسك ما
بتغيب ل مالي ولا
اولادي على حبك ما في
حبيب اسو شي في العمل الصحفي ما فيش
مواعيد ما فيش حياه مش منظمه حياه هيك
مخربطه يعني ما بتتنا يعني المناسبات
الاجتماعيه هذ يلغيها من حياتك يعني صله
الارحام تكاد
يعني نبطل يعني
خلاص حد قاللك ان انا بدي اطلع على
[موسيقى]
الجزيره حد قاللك
ان مكفي
انت
ننوه لهذا الخبر العاجل الذي ننقله على
شبكه الجزيره حيث استشهد عدد من افراد
عائله الزميل وائل الدحدوح بمن فيه زوجته
وابنه وابنته في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف منزل
الزميل وائل الدح كان معنا قبل قليل و تبع
القصف الذي سدف المنطقه التي استشهد فيها
عدد من افراد
[موسيقى]
عائل لكن راينا انه من الواجب ان نعود
سريعا رغم كل شيء
فساحه والمحاور ما زالت تشتعل كما ترون
بالغارات وبقص مدفعي والتطورات متلاحقه
فرايت ان من واجبي رغم الوجع ورغم الجرح
النازف ان اعود سريعا والتقيم من خلال
عدسه الكاميرا عبر مواقع التواصل اعطيكم
العافيه واسالكم الدعاء
دائما السلام
عليكم